hey guys I'm Jess and I'm Eddie and we
are dipping our toe in dreams today but
we're not just playing any old creations
we're gonna play the scary ones but
we're not gonna play Petey in silent
hill's because those have been doing the
rounds and I feel like we're all pretty
aware of them
there are a ton more horror games to be
played on dreams that people have
created for better and worse so without
further ado I actually lied we kind of
are playing Petey but we're not playing
the Petey recreation you're probably
aware of what we're gonna start with is
Petey second floor what could go wrong
so second floor oh yeah we are on the
second yeah oh [ __ ] the radio family
shot to death yeah the radio from
Petey's you point PC I haven't played
Petey so this is this is quite um my
first experience let's go through the
door no way can I not go through the
door no where's this big X what's oh you
can go wait but no I'm just back at the
beginning now oh my goodness guys this
is how everyone played paid somebody was
just shot there oh god it's happening
again
can we see I was playing I would just
run cuz I'm so scared I'm sorry if you
can't pick up my voice cuz I'm covering
my business okay oh so it's okay I
really don't want to play anymore and
this is the first game I'm really
unhappy actually like physically and
mentally it's gonna be it's all gonna be
fine oh look the stars oh no I don't
want to go in there this is where the
person gets shot okay I'm piecing it
together I'm not okay with this at all
okay okay that's not where he was before
it's in my head like I wish we got here
what do we got here I just heard a light
switch go oh god kill him
what
they went to the trolls car retrieve the
right are we doing it on his why whoa
and there's Oh Oh God [ __ ] yeah of
course you just want to go say hi
I'm sure sho go alright unfortunately I
guess it's my turn you have to spend one
night just one night that's it
I like steaks just want you to be
careful oh ok so it started Huff like
it's definitely a quicker ramp Oh shite
alright some horrible things have
happened
Oh God Oh Syl the key required of course
I bet it's on one of the dead guys find
the Silva Kay I'm too scared
oh my god
oh you smell oh you're back in the oh
that's that first room you are in
yeah but what is coming in here achieved
oh oh just a oh my god what is this
amazing
can I do anything no I just enjoy it's
literally on Rails it's literally all
the key oh no oh my god
oh lucky oh my gosh wait look at that
was giant Oh Shh Oh he's ripped if the
key get the key never trust your
grandmother what a good touch oh no oh
no we are literally getting eaten alive
is this how it ends please no yeah we
just died amazing
looks a little Spacey so that's nice
we're gonna thump it first because I
believe in you big surf 77 Wow
simultaneous whoa my gosh
it's so amazing oh hello yes hi it's a
robot friend it's just a little freaky
space is always a little freaky Oh No
why would you turn the lights out what
have you done or something appears out
there I'm gonna go I feel like this is
gonna turn into SCP containment breach
and I am NOT here for it keep waiting
for something or like something is
definitely gonna jump out oh my god
something busted all the way through
there okay this is a horror game it has
a lot of thumbs-up called insane the
hell Oh what's a big bad thing oh yes
electric ribs guts a ripped out oh wow
okay
no no it's boogie on down to horror town
okay this wall seems to be covered in
guts I like a little hoodie a lot like
so much so I know I would like to buy
one okay just some creepy veins on the
wall yeah I mean that's that's every
room say go in it okay hi oh my god
are we being eaten why would I go in
here I don't know there's nothing in
here except for oh my god wait oh wait
you're still going what's good oh I
think maybe it closed up yeah yeah oh my
goodness don't eat you just in case it
kills you it's just like that level in
Halo 3 when you going this is this is
truly the goriest thing this is I've
seen it sometime it's just cool to see
what people are doing as proof of course
oh well that was very cool it's a cool
poetry the most important waiting room
in existence which is way too deep for a
Tuesday afternoon which it is here as
we're recording this but you know what
that's fine while here feel free to
explore kill time and mingle with any
other morally ambiguous life-forms who
may be with you hey could you get back
to that waiting room please do some
maintenance
don't don't go back I'm not going back
definitely don't go back oh no oh my
controllers vibrating I thought you
would all want to know
oh gosh someone's how garden who is it I
don't know wait here we go
oh really not safe for you to be here oh
it's off the wall oh my god apart
please go back no don't go through there
oh gosh this is the room yeah chills
again this keeps happening oh you
totally fell for it what oh no I mean
everyone is having human being I'm gonna
be punished well you're in purgatory for
the rest of your life good job so here
we are a dead space which I would
imagine is some kind of recreation of
dead space the game will be all right go
god this is creepy it's okay you have a
gun yeah but I'm fighting Oh
my punching doesn't seem to work you you
gotta get it if it's anything like the
og dead space you gotta get it slims oh
maybe you could punch it in the kneecaps
there's one behind you there's one in
front definitely not gonna surprise this
if I don't punch him so many times will
you punch the other one no no oh my gosh
okay alright well there's just a few of
the games we found to let us know if
there's any great horror games you found
that we haven't played today and which
one I'm scared you the most I'm not
gonna say [ __ ]
so thanks dreams see you next time
[Music]